So why do we use paid ads? Well, I'm gonna tell you. I'm gonna share a quick story. If
you guys haven't heard the story already, great. If you have, bear with me for just
one moment. 2019, I realized in order for me to hit my goal, my goal at the time was
I wanted to get to $100,000 per month in revenue. And I realized I couldn't do that being a
salesman for somebody else. I couldn't do that by being an employee. And so I'm like,
I gotta figure this out. But at the time, I had about $8,000 in revenue coming in. I
had SEO deals. I had a little bit of lead gen and I had some paper lead, had no commission,
and had one or two flat fee deals. And I took inventory of my stuff and I almost forgot
about these couple of flat fee deals. And I looked at it and I'm like, dude, these guys
have been the most low maintenance of any of them. So why don't I do more of that? And
I'm like, okay, it's got to be that. It's got to be that flat fee stuff because in the
winter it's not going to go down. I'm going to be able to calculate everything. It's going
to be the same, you know, it just made sense to me. Okay. So I started realizing, I'm like,
I'm going to do the math. How do I get to $100,000? And I'm like, okay, well, I know
that if I build a site today, it's going to take a minimum of three to six months, three
if I'm really good at doing my due diligence, six if I'm okay. And if I do a bad job, I'm
going to need to spend 12, 18 months before a site ranks. Started doing the math. I'm
like, I'm going to need this many sites and this much ranking and assuming this many don't
work, I'm going to need to spend a lot of money every month to scale this puppy up.
And so I figured out, I'm like, okay, well, you know, and by the way, just so everybody
knows, I heard of this concept. I wasn't the first one to invent it. And this whole strategy
of giving leads in advance, Costco invented it and probably somebody before them. But
I heard of this idea of why don't you run a little bit of ads to juice it up? Why don't
you run a little bit of ads to get the phones ringing? And I'm like, that's a, that's a
great concept. And so I started running with it. And so in 2020, the beginning of 2020,
that's when I really took hold of this concept. I'm like, Hey, what if we could use other
people's money to scale? What if we didn't actually need to build the website before
we got the deal? What if we could set up a landing page, push traffic, get the lead,
get the deal and then build out the property? What would that look like? And so that's why
we use ads. We use ads to speed up the deal. So if you have a site right now and it fits
the criteria for module one and it's producing consistent leads, you probably don't need
to run ads. Okay. The thing that I like about it though, is it does speed up the deal. It
does allow you that let's say the winter comes and it gets a little slow on the organic side,
pop in the ads and it supplements. You know what else I like about it? GMB goes down,
throw in the ads, supplements it. Okay. So there's a number of reasons, but the number
one reason is we are trying to speed this process up. So I'm going to share really,
briefly three reasons, the three main reasons why I love running ads. Number one reason is speed,
as I've already mentioned. Okay. I don't know about you, but I ain't got four to six months
to wait for a little towing site or a little, I shouldn't even say towing. I hate towing.
A concrete site, a tree service. I don't have four to six months to wait. I want to hit my goals
today, baby. I don't want to wait. Okay. So by running these ads, it's allowing us to put up
a landing page, push ads, get calls today, sell today or tomorrow or the next day, get the deal
and then build out and be making money the entire time. Number two reason is this is going to allow
us to scale. Okay. A lot of you are in the same position I was in in 2000, the end of 2019,
beginning of 2020 where it's like, yeah, I get this. I love it. I'm sold, but I don't have the
money to build out a hundred sites and time, you know, hosting times a hundred, call tracking
number times a hundred, whatever, hosting domain, all this times a hundred. Okay. I didn't have the
money. I don't want to have to pay a VA times a hundred to go and do the backlinks and the content
and all this stuff. I don't, I didn't have the money. So if you want to scale, the best way to
scale in real estate, physical real estate and in digital real estate is called, it's by using OPM.
Other people's money. So by using ads, it allows us to get the deal upfront, use the money from the
deal to build out the property that we own, the asset and to scale the sucker up. Number three
reason is this allows us to test. This is the third reason we use Google ads. Okay. So what do I mean
by that? Well, it allows us to actually put up a one pager that takes a couple of minutes, 30 minutes
to an hour, set up an ad, which take us a couple of minutes, 30 minutes to an hour until you get
fast at it. I can do it in five minutes now. It allows us to spend a couple of bucks, probably up
to a hundred and we can go and test out a market. Meaning maybe the tool that we looked at, maybe it
was mangles, maybe it was keyword planner, maybe it was SEMrush, maybe the tool said there's volume,
but maybe there's not because these tools aren't always accurate. I'd rather spend a hundred bucks
in two days of my time than I would spend six months of my time and heaven knows how many
thousands of dollars just to find out there's no volume. I'm ranked number one whoop-de-doo.
There's no, there's no volume. There's no people calling or worse. There's no hungry business
owner. So if I get in, I can set this thing up quick. I could spend a hundred bucks. I get a lead.
Okay, cool. I know there's volume. And now I can use that lead to go start calling around and see
if there's actually hungry business owners in the area. Guys, I love this so much because
it allows you to almost go into the future, say, Hey, in theory, if I did have this thing ranking,
if it was producing, would there be somebody that would pay for this? Yes or no. Okay, awesome.
There's leads coming in. There's business owners that are hungry. Let's fricking do this. Those
are the three reasons why we use Google ads. Let's dive in and get some ads set up, baby.